Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel we're spending the next four
days fishing for Halloween seeing
beautiful scenery
I think we'll stop guys salmon eating
good food I'm a camping it's gonna be a
great adventure come along for the ride
[Music]
all right guys you ready to go
[Applause]
[Music]
we're here in Whittier Alaska and we're
about to get on a ferry to go to Valdez
well it's about a six hour ferry ride to
get to the city of Valdez and we're
gonna sail through Prince William's
sound which is in my opinion one of the
most beautiful places in all of Alaska
we're gonna see lots of glaciers and
there's a really good chance of seeing
whales hey Jacob can you see that
Glacier right behind you
there's another Glacier out there oh
there's another Glacier out there
there's a pot of killer whales that just
swam in front of the boat
s oh we got another whale
[Music]
all right everybody Welcome to Valdez
Valdez holds the record in Alaska for
the most snow in a year at 96 feet and
the most snow in the day 18 feet
okay
it's got a nice little kitchen in here I
wonder if the TV has any problem with
overheating look at that
that's pretty
oh check it out they've got the the ski
handrail here
oh yeah got us some bunk beds up here
yeah oh mind the beam here
you guys gonna pick your bedroom well
you couldn't tell by looking out the
window but it's almost 10 o'clock we've
got to get our kids to bed I'm gonna put
the camera down I'm gonna see you guys
in the morning
Tommy
wake up bud
hey Jacob
catchy
it's me Tommy and Jake are here at the
small boat harbor in Valdez and we are
gonna go fishing
all right guys here's our boat tell them
why don't you go hop down in there and
I'll hand you stuff okay
everyone to take and see almost every
major port in Alaska has a boat rental
place and as long as you're taking the
Coast Guard safety class or have some
boating experience you can rent your own
boat and go out fishing and it's a
fraction of the cost of doing a charter
boat and frankly I think it's a little
more fun
foreign
first thing we're going to do is drop
some shrimp pots and let those soak all
day long when we come back we'll get
some shrimp
we've only been out of the harbor three
minutes I already see a whale
right there
is that cool Tommy do you see him yes
let's get the shrimp pots ready
yeah shrimp pellets
we're at a little over 300 feet deep
we're gonna right
dude
all right we got our shrimp pots out
time to go fishing all right we got
about an hour drive we're gonna go out
far out into the ocean well guys check
this out
sea otters
minutes and we've already seen a dozen
otters they're so fluffy
check it out that's blight Reef it's
where the Exxon Valdez oil tanker ran
aground and caused the oil spill back
when I was in school
got a jig on this we're in a big wide
flat area with about 70 feet of water
and we're gonna try to see if we can't
catch a halibut the current's moving
really gently and there's almost no wind
so we're gonna drop down and just kind
of drift along until we get into a
pocket of halibut
look at this oh I got a I had a big head
oh it came up and hit it oh oh it just
popped off oh
let's see what we got oh I see colors oh
get him on there I think that's a jig oh
there we go
there we go it's a hell of it
it's a bun
it's pretty small should we keep him
yeah it's an embarrassingly small
halibut but I think we should keep one
there we go
yay small he snagged
there you go there you go first hell of
it
yeah oh
wow
there we go
oh Jake you got one right here here
watch this
you want to keep him let's hit him back
oh he got away
that's okay we're gonna get another one
there's so many oh yeah look look look
look at it we'll throw them back
all right
there we go there's another one
oh that's a nice little one
oh there you go oh
oh he got him right now you got him
right in the private parts Jacob
[Music]
nice and healthy one
I was busy dealing with Tommy's fish and
Jake put the Allure back all by himself
Jake didn't hooked it
that's a big one Jake
that's not a bad one Jake you wanna you
wanna keep fishing or you want to be
done I'm done
here you go
[Music]
you want to keep him yes okay no here
come here
oh there he goes he's off
[Music]
I'll tell you what guys those weren't
huge but that was loads of fun we're
gonna catch about 12 halibut let most of
them go but we still got a couple hours
let's go try for some rockfish
look there's some Rockfish right there
you can see the signals yeah that's all
those little lines of Rockfish they're
right on the edge
got one of my signature series rods here
I'm gonna try that yeah there's
something on yeah
I gotta deal with my oh that's
oh look at this
here check this out that's a link card
that's a nice one
no we can't keep them though it's a lean
card this is very tasty but they're out
of season
don't put your fingers in there
that's a nice tasty fish but
there he goes
there you go nice nice black bass
there we go close it up
that is a massive big rock fish good job
Tom that's a nice black bass yeah
see some color
is that a house no that's a big lean
card top whoa look at the size of that
Link Card
pull them up
nice black guys bring him over here
and there you go that's another big one
Tom
I got one oh
right there Jake
there we go yeah
oh four
yeah you go you got a bass oh
that's a quill back
around it
all right
there we go one two three four five six
seven eight and nine that's our limit
all right guys we're slimy and wet but
we got lots of fish we're gonna head
back and check our shrimp pot
I'm sorry Dad
okay oh
stop
oh
absolutely nothing in there that's not
good
for nothing in there but a jellyfish
there you go
oh that was disappointing
oh that shrimping was a bus but we can't
complain we got a lot of fish
okay
[Music]
there's not a ton of fish but that's not
bad
if you go and pull that I'll take care
of the other stuff
oh man do you gotta you gotta play that
right next to mine and I look small
enough as it is
foreign
big pile of fish here we still have a
couple days left in our Venture I don't
want our fish going bad so I'm going to
take it here to get it frozen hi
16 pounds and change that's not bad this
guy's gonna vacuum seal it and freeze it
for me and pick it up tomorrow
oh boys did you have a fun time yeah
oh well guys we had a great day but it's
getting late and we've got to get these
kids to bed I'll see you guys in the
morning
please but it's time to go north we're
doing some camping tonight
pick up our fish
thank you very much yeah
I'm so glad I did that
well we're all checked out we've got our
fish I think it's time to head north of
China what do you guys say
all right let's do it
chinchilla chinchilla no it's chitna
when you combine lots of snow with lots
of mountains you get lots of waterfalls
all right guys we're gonna count
waterfalls
one
two that's number five
you guys want to see a tunnel
is an old railroad tunnel that was dug
out by hand unfortunately it was never
finished because the work party devolved
into a gun battle and they ended up
shooting each other
there's waterfall number 10 over there
oh there's waterfall number 16. the best
part of this drive is the view of the
mountains
that's a wall of snow over there
it's the end of June
scurvies hit the Nichols family we need
to get Tommy some more vitamin C
there he goes my tears humbug
all right you want some hamburgers
all right I'm gonna pull over and make
some hamburgers here
feel that heat in here
hey we just give that about oh 20 30
miles and it should be done
[Music]
oh almost lost in there
mommy there you go
what do you think Mom
they're good they ate those too quick
we're gonna go ahead and put some more
here all right
all right we found ourselves a nice
little camping spot on the banks of the
Copper River oh I think the Copper River
is a little bit high right now
there's the fee station
got a nice campsite got a nice fire I
think it's time for a nice dinner we're
gonna make halibut tacos tonight
all right look who showed up hey Melanie
hello
so my sister Melanie and her friend
Megan are joining us hello so so Megan
you're doing the tent and Melanie you're
in the car yes I need one of my boys to
set up the ten
don't go over here look at my lovely
sous chef here
[Music]
you ready for tacos
all right we got fresh fried halibut we
got some tortillas and anybody who wants
to heat up their tortilla take it up
here to the tortilla Rock and just lay
it right there we've got a guacamole
salsa we got a cilantro lime sauce mango
pico de gallo salsa fresh cilantro
lettuce tomatoes limes Peppers go for it
no by the way guys save room for dessert
because they had cookies and cream
stuffed marshmallows
there we go that looks pretty good huh
you like the tacos it's very good so
good so good
I think this is my third or fourth time
filming me catching and cooking halibut
we always do halibut tacos there's a
reason there's a reason
well we've been enjoying dinner poor
Beck has been dealing with kids pooping
oh is that is that the bathroom yeah
wait do you like the Outhouse yeah who
wants to roast marshmallows we got jumbo
sized marshmallows and we got
marshmallows stuffed with cookies and
cream
for you
is that good
this is the greatest thing I've ever
tasted I'm done
look at that oh yeah that's the kind of
man you married that's perfect
cookies and cream not bad
oh my goodness there's only one of these
left I can't believe it ah
all right Tom would you help me with the
dishes yes by that I mean do the dishes
thank you
I'm proud of you son oh I want some
fresh bread for breakfast tomorrow so
I'm gonna go ahead and make some bread
dough and let it sit overnight
we'll just let this sit till tomorrow
all right everyone's sleeping
I'm handy then is right here wait a
minute what have you guys been up to
nothing dams making watch your language
young man
oh you see your hands there oh listen I
told you use toilet paper
oh thank goodness
[Music]
Nathan found the coolest sword stick
ever it's
Luke look at that that's a great sword
stick I asked the boys to go get
firewood they delivered
how about you just drop it right there
I'll chop it up from here yo that's
that's good
well I appreciate all you've done with
the wood but I've got some bad news
bedtime
we gotta get this one cleaned up wash
those feet grab the feet
I'm cold one of the buttons no it's fine
all right
see you in the morning we're gonna catch
loads of fish in the morning
got the boys to bed and just admiring
what a gorgeous campsite this is
look at that
a young eagle
that's pretty you gotta admit that's
really pretty
well either way like that well guys it's
about 11 o'clock and it's starting to
rain I think it's time to go to bed look
at this I'm brushing my teeth this must
be what people call glamping
well guys it's late we gotta put the
camera up I'll see you guys in the
morning
[Music]
his dad's job is to make sure the fire
is nice and warm by the time everyone
gets up
put our bread here
there we go we got some reindeer sausage
we also got some Maple sausage here
you know
I have to like nope I don't know
this is amazing thank you what do you
think of the food
now we got breakfast in us we got to get
all packed up and get out of here cause
we are going fishing as a family
sprinkle a little out of time
beds pop up
yeah you don't hey Megan you good back
there
[Music]
all these people are here for the same
reason we are they're going dip knitting
for sockeyes and King Salmon
all right we'll see you guys back in
acreage okay sounds good all right take
care
all right boys hop in do you guys want
to go fishing yeah
foreign
guys we're gonna go on a dip knitting
Charter with AK expeditions
you got your salmon totes got it you got
that
all right hey how you doing tomorrow yes
sir hi Mark
all right guys this right here is the
Copper River and right now we've got the
red salmon run or the sockeye salmon run
and we're gonna get in this boat and
we're gonna go and try to scoop them out
with it now
up and over
yeah
this is one of those rivers that just
looks mean doesn't it
I was wondering where the nuts were
pull them a quick hand over hand what
that does is that collapses this net and
clapses the fish in the net
hey
go ahead and get them in all right
and the fish gets in there you'll feel
it wiggling around
wow that was fast
it's a king yeah it's a king sound we're
gonna set that one back he's a little
small yet
hey Mega grab my guys we've only been
fishing 30 seconds and Becca already
caught a king salmon now we're allowed
to keep 70 red salmon but only one king
salmon so that was a small one so we put
them back
yeah
oh
[Music]
David
salmon let's see
red salmon yeah look at that Nathan you
got the first Keever high five
the sockeye salmon or a red salmon this
is the best eating salmon
so dip netting is pretty simple but it's
a lot of work you go Upstream you put
your Nets in and you drag them
Downstream to try to snare the salmon as
they swim up
[Music]
hey can you hold on to that yeah
so right now we're just keep going
Upstream dragging our Nets Downstream
then repeating the cycle over and over
again
[Music]
it's a fish
is it a soccer yeah that's a Sockeye
look at that
that's two
well you catch them dip netting you
gotta clip the tail
see how pale he is he'll start to turn
silver as he dies
now the reason why we're dead for
sockeyes is that they won't bite a hook
you can only catch a Sockeye by snagging
them flossing them or netting them yeah
boy
there we go that's three
there you go
[Music]
here
no don't don't use Mama's coat don't do
mom's toes
there you go nice pretty oh
pretty soccer number four
you're going on the river you're just
kind of feeling the bottom and then all
of a sudden the net will start shaking
You Pull It in you got a fish
miles from the ocean and there is a seal
over there
my wish came true
that's not too bad
high five yeah
look at that
harder number six number six number six
Mega Nathan you got one
yes the fishy Dance Team box one team
dead zero
oh
Becca
that's a king salmon
that's a big one
oh look at that
biggest fish of the trip that is
n't so let them sash it James
it's like a schoolyard for all here all
right
oh
you got a king what a king now you can
see why we let the other one go when
they're all silver the way you tell is
the spot's on the tail yeah sockeyes
don't have the spots on the tail like
that
he and Mommy's kicking our butts you
gotta do something about this we got an
upper game you know I think it was the
fishy dance it may have helped yeah
thank you
nice Sockeye
another thing
beautiful King I like the one we kept
though only allowed to keep one king per
family
team dad just came up from behind with
two fish
pajamas
you got a kick salmon
smells like moms well yeah our fish are
never as big as moms I think that's the
biggest king salmon you've ever caught
yeah high five buddy
yes
yes do the salmon dance do the salmon
dance
Hey Jake
well guys we had an awesome time but
it's time to go and clean some fish hey
guys you have fun
yeah
that's a pile of fish
that is not bad
but now we gotta clean them
that is why they call them red salmon
the meat is redder than any of the other
salmon
how heavy is that it's pretty heavy okay
you ready
that is just salmon fillets
if you guys want to do this too I'll put
a link to AKA expedition's Guide Service
in the video description below well babe
once again you've caught a bigger King
Salmon than me
we've got a long drive back to acreage
foreign
midnight and we made it home and you can
see how light it is outside I got a
bunch of tired little boys back here and
I gotta put the camera up see you in the
morning good morning everybody we made
it home
[Music]
all right we're gonna let that sit for
about four or five hours
thank you
foreign
smoking that red salmon but we got
friends coming over and we're gonna be
making up that King Salmon
honey garlic whipped Brie with smoked
salmon and crackers
we're trying some of that
well that's a different kind
s
[Music]
thank you
we've got king salmon fillet with a
little bit of maple syrup brown sugar
and lots of salt and pepper we got
cornbread wannabe Breezy salads couscous
with Craisins and basil and then we've
got whipped Brie honey garlic and smoked
salmon on crackers and we got parfait
for dessert if the boys eat their dinner
mama
really good
let's put the oh it was really good do
you like it oh yeah it's really good
very good Tommy you like it
still in his mouth this is very nice
[Applause]
[Music]
oh did you enjoy the meal I enjoy
did you enjoy the trip I love love trip
listen hopefully you guys like this
video too so if you want to see more
like this make sure to click subscribe
to the outdoor Boys YouTube channel we
put out new videos every Saturday
morning if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning hit that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching